imagine you're in a ship with a hundred
Sailors in the middle of the Atlantic
the captain is drunk and he fires a
cannon at the deck of the ship blasting
a hole straight through the bottom the
ship starts filling with water so you
yell hey let's plug the hole and use
these buckets to dump the water
overboard but the sailors are all drunk
too and they yell back no let's reload
the cannon and use it to make more holes
in the ship and let's use the buckets to
fill the ship with even more water and
they reload and fire the cannon at the
deck again while the rest start bailing
water into the boat totally insane right
you see the problem and you know the
only possible solution to the problem
but everyone else is hellbent on making
the problem
worse now you know how anyone with a
drop of Common Sense feels watching
Europe destroy itself the solution ution
is obvious but the leaders are
absolutely obsessed with making the
problem worse Christian Theologian and
social critic Oz Guinness has been
warning Europeans about this for decades
he was born in China during World War II
his parents were medical missionaries
after the Communist Revolution in China
his family was forced out he spent the
next few decades in Great Britain before
moving to the United States the man has
seen it all at the recent art conference
in London Dr Guinness pointed out that
since the enlightenment the West has
been trying to replace God and
Christianity with something else namely
reason why do we need God why do we need
Christianity when we've got
reason how has that worked out for
Europe the intended
replacement has proved Absolut abolutely
inadequate in other words the
enlightenment summed up in one word as
reason was intended to be the impl
replacement for the Christian faith
leading Humanity forward with progress
under reason and not under
God now Europe is being confronted by
Marxism and Islam and reason has
suddenly become completely unreasonable
so unre reasonable that it can't respond
to
challenges but you can see not only from
the waves I've mentioned the Red Wave of
radical
Marxism the rainbow wave of the radical
sexual
Revolution and the Black Wave of radical
islamism but you can also see how
secular liberalism itself has
failed what happens when the educated
Elite use their reason to attack reason
itself ironically it started with
reason but now reason understood by
postmodernists is European power or
masculine power or white power and not
Universal
reason the educated Elite attack
religion but their Replacements turn
into replacement
religions they tried to replace
God but they produced a series of qu I
religions take
Marxism it begins by claiming that all
criticism begins with the criticism of
religion and it ends as a religion which
stifles all
criticism liberalism will unite us and
yet liberalism crumbles at the first
sign of
danger but you can see even since
October the 7th how much of liberalism
is demonstr L shifted from
Liberal to post liberal and even to
highly illiberal and there's absolutely
no question that the intended
replacement the enlightenment secularism
has failed it will not do the job for
Western
Civilization drunk European leaders shot
a cannonball through the bottom of their
own ship and now that people are
realizing the replac ment didn't work
they're suddenly looking for something
that might actually solve the
problem second thing equally
clear is that while there has only been
a relative Resurgence of the Christian
faith in some circles significant
circles
too what's been much more
clear is that the renewal of faith is
now seen to be
indispensable it's indispensable on an
individual level and on a civilizational
level first the individual level humans
need three things on a personal level
meaning
belonging and
purpose and there's no deeper
answers than the Christian faith rooted
in
Judaism but civilization also needs more
than Enlightenment reason
offers but what we see now goes far
beyond that because as we're discussing
civilization you can see that faith is
critical it's often called the three
Rs the roots of
civilization the restraints of
civilization and the renewal of
civilization the renewal part seems like
it would come in handy right about now
but that's not what the secular world
view gives you for the secular world you
only have I was saying this at breakfast
Decline and fall
entropy there's no other way you decline
you will fall and that's part of the run
and rules of the course of history but
not biblically Decline and fall your
civilization may be great but it won't
last forever it will eventually Decline
and after a period of decline it will
fall but the biblical pattern is a bit
different for Jews and for Christians
that natural pairing is not decline and
fall but Exile and
return yes as Exile when people disobey
the ways of the Lord and don't live as
he called us to live it produces chaos
and displacement and finally
Exile you can Decline and the decline
May lead to Exile but Exile isn't the
same as the fall of
civilization but if people return to him
he returns to them and restores their
fortunes and so you have a pairing of
Exile and return rather than Decline and
fall so even in periods of deep decline
which we're experiencing now we have the
hope of return if we return to the Lord
properly from a secular perspect
perspective you look around at Europe
and say we're declining rapidly
declining collapse seems
inevitable from a Christian perspective
you look around at Europe and say we
turned away from God and now we're in a
period of Exile Even in our own Nations
but we've seen this pattern over and
over again and we know God can restore
us we're at The Showdown moment in
Western civiliz Iz
ation will the radical
revolutions regenerate society as they
promised or
not they will not I guarantee you they
will
not will the secular Enlightenment of
liberalism encourage Humanity to go
forward and progress with reason alone
without
God or not
it will not I promise you it will
not but also is the god of
Sinai the god of the burning bush the
god of the burning mountain and our Lord
with the Call of Galilee Are these
things
true or
not they are indeed sir so Europeans
became drunk on Prosperity a Prosperity
they achieved because of of their
religion and these drunk Europeans then
came up with the brilliant idea of
replacing their religion they fired a
cannonball through the deck of their own
ship and it's been taking on water for
some time now the solution is obvious
but instead of returning to God and
bringing about the renewal of
civilization they're busy reloading the
cannon and bailing water into the
ship welcome to human Reason unaided by
faith in the one who created it if you'd
like to watch and share the full speech
by Oz Guinness the link is in the
description box
[Music]